[Music]
all right this is one question friday
where we answer a grand total of
one question from a listener uh one
lucky listener gets to ask a question me
and sam are gonna give a give our raw
off-the-cuff answer we haven't seen the
question before jonathan has it
and um
these are tips and they are just the
tips
as i like to say
we try not to go too deep all right
jonathan you want to hit us with a
question hey guys my name is brian and
i'm calling about ghost kitchens
i've first learned about ghost kitchens
on pods so thanks for that
so i developed a model to implement a
couple of ghost kitchen concepts into my
restaurant i had great success lifted my
margins over 450 percent over six months
with just one of the concepts
now i'm looking to scale the business by
offering licensing agreements for
operators in other markets to use these
concepts including the branding recipes
etc
it's very simple you find an operator
that wants a new rev new stream
and wants to do a ghost kitchen and they
can start slinging product within a
matter of weeks i've researched the
model that much larger companies are
using where they leverage celebrities to
sell these concepts
my model is better it's cheaper and the
recipes are second to none in the space
assuming you didn't have the following
in the platform that you do how would
you go about selling this idea to
restaurant operators across the nation
where would you start
sidebar i love what you guys do on the
pod
sam i just signed up for copy that and i
can't wait to get started good man
so what's his name by the way
we're gonna call him joe
no it was uh
i don't remember so thanks for the
question ryan yeah
two weeks in a row we have one question
and we do not know the guy's name again
it sounded smart it sounded like he's
got his game plan together but so let's
recap the business is is what all right
so he owned
here's what i understood he owns a
restaurant
and then he added in a ghost kitchen
meeting he like created a ghost brand
which is like what that means is if you
go on doordash or ubereats or one of
these delivery apps
you can order from a restaurant but
there's no physical restaurant for that
thing it's just a virtual brand and his
restaurant would then like have the
packaging so let's say my normal
restaurant is shawn's pizza
well then i could also have a ghost
brand called sean you know uh you know
silly sandwiches and silly sandwich if i
get an order from silly sandwiches my
restaurant crew will just like package
it up as a silly sandwich order and
it'll be ready to go and so i'm kind of
running multiple restaurants out of one
restaurant is the idea and why does the
restaurant owner want to do that with
them versus on their own so what he said
was
he i don't know if he created that ghost
brand or he added that gross brand but
he said my ever improved my restaurant
marge is 450 percent so he forexed his
restaurant's margin so let's say a
normal restaurant has i mean it sounds a
little unbelievable right like let's say
he had i don't know six percent margins
before
uh you know don't do public math but
he's saying that that basically forexed
his margins i'm not sure exactly what
he's talking about here that's cool but
you know what business would be way
better is do you remember alex her
mozzie's business exactly gym launch gym
launch exactly what i was going to
recommend go ahead well i think he well
maybe you weren't going to say this i
was going to say
go listen to the episode
um he that what his model was he had a
gym and he was like all right how do i
get my gym to be more profitable and
then he figured out like a sales method
to get his gym if he opened up a gym he
figured out a sales method that would
get him to have a bunch of customers
paying high prices and making a bunch of
money on a gym and his friend
at a mastermind one day was like yo you
need to like not do this you need you
don't need to open up 50 gyms doing this
you need to go teach other gyms how to
do this like your product isn't the gym
it's a sales process to make any gym
more profitable and so that's what he
did then he created gym launch which
would basically advertise say hey are
you a gym owner i can help you make an
extra 100 000 year guaranteed um using
my sales method to get you more
customers paying higher prices and
they'd be like all right cool and then
he would fly out to that gym and he
would spend the next i don't know a
couple weeks or whatever
implementing that process so that they
would then have more revenue more
customers coming in using his thing and
he would teach them hey here's how you
do it
here's your offer here's your facebook
ads when they come in here's your sales
script then you sign them up for a free
trial then here's how you close them
then here's how you upsell them protein
powders and this other stuff here's how
you upsell them training packages that's
the that's the sales process and he
built a multi-million dollar business
doing that if you did that for
restaurants to teach them how to do this
that sounds like a business
100 no-brainer that's what i would do
except so you said that alex would fly
out there eventually he wasn't actually
flying out there eventually it was
basically it was not fair to call it a
course but he would if that was part of
it so he would teach you stuff but then
also he would be like here's the
facebook ads like i've already made them
for you you can use my facebook ads that
i already made here's the drip email
sequence here's the script that we use
here's everything and then he would say
oh by the way if you don't want to do
this and you just want me to run the ads
fine pay us and we'll do it and here's
how you sell protein you want to sell
protein and by the way the protein that
sells best we just went and bought it so
we already own it so if you want to get
on a subscription and we'll just send it
to you and here's how you sell it we'll
just go ahead and do all that for you
anyway so i would 100
do that we
on that pod we go alex what's a good
market for uh gym launch buffer blank
and we actually didn't have that many
good answers
the answers this restaurant business
yeah this is the answer this is a great
thing that's a great example and like
lucky for
you know our our buddy here ryan we're
calling him for a second um that
there's like a pretty great blueprint to
follow right like there's a blueprint
that he was very public about how he did
it he's now exited the business and also
by the way this is what his business
does now is it invests in other people
doing this model and he's like dude i
already know how to do this i can scale
it up now you have to be at some scale
before he'll do it but like
he gives away the free content
um on how he structured gym launch to do
to be able to do this so that's i think
what you should do which is like
restaurant launcher ghost the ghost
kitchen process the ghost kitchen system
which is basically hey if you're if
you're a independent restaurant
and
trust me it's tough foot traffic is
tough with cove but it's tough it's blah
blah everyone's ordering delivery
here's how you can increase your margins
but well here's how i did it you kind of
open up your financials you say look i
was making thirty two thousand dollars
you know um a quarter doing it this way
now i make 58 000 and that extra bit is
from my ghost kitchen concept and here's
how i do it
and basically they can either pay you
for the course on how they can do it or
you'd hit them with the alex from oz
where you're like
if this sounds too complicated
i can also do it for you and if you
qualify i'll do it for you what he did
was risk free he's like here's my offer
for you
you pay me nothing
i only get money once i've increased
your sales by over
30 000
000 so once you've made that much more
money off this then i get to get my cut
of 30
of whatever the total is that that we
get and i'm so confident that i'm going
to be able to raise your sales that i'll
do that for you i'll take the risk on
that how does that sound and they're all
like yeah you're going to fly out here
you're going to implement your process
it's worked for you and you're saying
that i only pay you once i'm making all
this extra money that's a pretty pretty
damn good offer and so you could do a
similar thing for the restaurant i saw a
guy the other day do a sales process
where he was like trying to sell a
service just like this and the let's
just say the restaurant owner was like
uh i don't know if i want to do that and
he goes
that's fine but how about this
we you implement what i say
and uh
if it works
i get a split of the revenue and the guy
goes great i'm 100 do that what's the
split and then the seller goes well how
about 50 50 and the buyer goes i don't
know man that's a lot and the seller
goes well but i'm i'm you know it's 50
50. it's free money for you i'm doing
all the work
and the guy goes well what if it blows
up you know like you're gonna get a lot
of money and the seller goes you know i
think you're right
well he goes he goes it might blow up
but i'll tell you what you might be
right fine we'll go back to the original
deal you only gonna pay five thousand
dollars and the guy goes okay fine
it was like it was like the best sale
sequence like it totally worked i was
like oh my god that's beautiful
um
yeah i would totally do this business as
well i think that that's way better i
would continue running the main thing
just so you're in the know and like
getting results that you could post to
social media but uh that's what i would
do too
is that it is that the answer
just the tip oh gaston what's the wi-fi
i can't no i can't get in
oh it's arg
connect your teams easier than
connecting your wi-fi hubspot grow
better all hands on deck
all right
how uh
you said that nun jumped out when you're
talking to alex are there any other
industries that jump out now that this
could work for
probably physical probably physical
therapists i would imagine doctors
offices and physical therapists
i think maybe barbers real estate
brokers so um every real estate broker
is like running their own little small
business
sometimes as part of a brokerage
sometimes their own brokerage
and uh there's a whole process to
basically like hey you should leave
caldwell bankers they're taking half of
your commission
um
i i spun out my own here's how i did it
here's how much more i make and i will
spin you out um of this big brokerage
firm i'll set up your website i'll set
up your back office legal legal
structure i'll set up your marketing
package i'll show you exactly how this
all works and you know like instead of
coldwell baker taking half of your
commission i will take five percent of
your commission uh you know to do this
so i think you could basically i think
selling a sales system
is a um
is a pretty good business to be in in
general
yeah i mean it's it's like
very very high margin i think that a lot
of course businesses top out at a
certain level i think when you're
selling a sales cycle or a sales product
like this i don't think you're i think
the the cap is way higher
by the way also now that alex carmozy's
not doing gym launch you could also just
do lit gym launch again like
you know now that he's like checked out
doing other [__] like you know you could
have always competed with him but like
he put a playbook out there he exited
the company there's it's still running
but like
you could just do it again you could
literally recycle his business i i think
this is so underrated just recycling
business ideas
um
once the person has exited and you know
they've let their foot out the gas or
they've expanded they've moved up market
it's like they just leave you an exact
playbook on what to do and um more often
than not that timing still will work
dude we we had a couple at the hustle we
had a few companies that would just copy
and paste our content and just create a
new newsletter and uh
they some of them got traction
yeah edit that out i don't want people
doing that now
[Laughter]
well it doesn't work in the end it's a
very short-term thing you know uh but
all right that's it you got the tip
[Music]
you